there's been a lot of ufo sightings
uh what do you think about those ufo
sightings and what do you think if any
of them
are
of extraterrestrial origin and we don't
see
giant civilizations out in the sky
how do you make sense of that then
i want to do some clearing of throats
which people like to do on this topic
right
they want to make sure you understand
they're saying this and not that right
so
i would say the analysis needs both a
prior and a likelihood
so
the prior is what are the scenarios that
are at all plausible in terms of what we
know about the universe and then the
likelihood is the particular actual
sightings like how hard are those to
explain through various means
i will establish myself as somewhat of
an expert on the prior i would say my
studies and things i've studied make me
an expert and i should stand up and have
an opinion on that and explain be able
to explain it
the likelihood however is not my area of
expertise that is i'm not a you know
pilot i don't do atmospheric studies of
things i haven't studied in detail the
various kinds of atmospheric phenomena
or whatever that might be used to
explain the particular sightings i can
just say from my amateur stance the
sightings look
damn puzzling
they do not look easy to dismiss the
attempts i've seen to easily dismiss
them seem to me to fail it seems like
these are pretty puzzling weird stuff
that
deserve an expert's attention so the in
terms of
considering asking what the likelihood
is so an analogy i would make is a
murder trial okay
on average if we say what's the chance
any one person murdered another person
as a prior probability maybe one in a
thousand people get murdered maybe each
person has a thousand people around them
who could plausibly have done it so the
prior probability of a murder is one in
a million
but we allow murder trials because often
evidence is sufficient to overcome a one
in a million prior
because the evidence is often strong
enough right
my guess rough guess for the ufos as
aliens scenarios some of them is the
prior is roughly one in a thousand
much higher than the usual murder trial
plenty high enough that strong physical
evidence could put you over the top to
think it's more likely than not
but i'm not an expert on that physical
evidence i'm going to leave that part to
someone else i'm going to say the prior
is pretty high this isn't a crazy
scenario so then i can elaborate on
where my prior comes from what scenario
could make most sense of this data
my scenario to make sense has
two main parts
first is panspermia siblings
so panspermia is the pros hypothesis
process by which life might have arrived
on earth from elsewhere
and a plausible time for that i mean it
would have to happen very early in
earth's history because we see life
early in his history and a plausible
time could have been during this stellar
nursery where the sun was born with many
other
stars in the same close proximity with
lots of rocks flying around able to move
things from one place to another
pans if a you know rock with life on it
from some rock with planet with life
came into that stellar nursery it
plausibly could have seeded many planets
in that stellar nursery all at the same
time they're all born at the same time
in the same place pretty close to each
other lots of rocks flying around okay
so a panspermia scenario would then
create siblings i.e
there would be say a few thousand
other
planets out there so after the nursery
forms it drifts it separates they drift
apart and so out there in the galaxy
there would now be a bunch of other
stars all formed at the same time and we
can actually spot them in terms of their
spectrum
and they would have um
then started on the same path of life as
we did with that life being seeded but
they would move at different rates
and
most likely most of them would never you
know reach an advanced level before the
deadline but maybe one other did
and maybe it did before us
so
if they did they could know all this and
they could go searching for their
siblings that is they could look in the
sky for the other stars with the mass
the spectrum that matches this the
spectrum that came from this nursery
they could identify their sibling stars
in the galaxy the thousand of them
and those would be of special interest
to them because they would think well
life might be on those
and they could go looking for them can
we just such a brilliant
mathematical philosophical
uh physical biological idea of um
panspermia siblings because we all kind
of started a similar time
in this local pocket
right of the universe
and so
that changes a lot of the math and so
that would create this correlation
between when advanced life might appear
no longer just random independent spaces
in space time there would be this
cluster perhaps and that allows
interaction between
the cluster yes non-grabby alien
civilizations like
kind of
primitive alien civilizations like us
with others and they might be a little
bit ahead that's so fascinating they
would probably be a lot ahead so the
puzzle is sure sure if if if they you
know if they've happened before us they
probably happened hundreds of millions
of years before us
less than a billion less than a billion
but still plenty of time that they could
have become grabby and fill the filled
the galaxy and gone and beyond so
there'd be plenty so the the fact is
they chose not to become grabby that
would have to be the interpretation
if we have pants permeability in time to
become grabby you said so yes they
should be playing
are we sure about this
again a hundred million years is enough
100 million so i told you before that i
said within 10 million years our
descendants will become grabby or not
and they'll have that choice okay right
and so they clearly more than 10 million
years earlier than us so they chose not
to but still go on vacation look around
so just not grabbing if they chose not
to expand that part that's going to have
to be a rule they set to not allow any
part of themselves to do it like
if they let any little ship fly away
with the ability to create a colony
the game's over then they have prevented
then the world the universe becomes
grabby from their origin with this one
colony right so in order to prevent
their civilization being grabby they
have to have a rule they enforce pretty
strongly that no part of them can ever
try to do that through
a global authoritarian regime or
through something that's internal to
that meaning it's part of the nature of
life
that it doesn't want as like an advanced
political officer in the brain or
whatever yes there's something in
human nature
that prevents you from or like like
alien nature right that as you get more
advanced you become lazier and lazier in
terms of exploration and expansion so i
would say they would have to have
enforced a rule against expanding and
that rule would probably make them
reluctant to let people leave very far
that you know any one vacation trip far
away could risk an expansion from the
six vacation trip so they would probably
have a pretty tight lid on just allowing
any travel out from their origin in
order to enforce this rule
but then we also know well they would
have chosen to come here so clearly they
made an exception from their general
rule to say okay but an expedition to
earth that should be allowed it could be
intentional exception or
incompetent exception but if incompetent
then they couldn't maintain this over
100 million years this policy of not
allowing any expansion so we have to see
they have successfully they not just had
a policy to try they succeeded over a
hundred million years in preventing the
expansion
that's a substantial competence let me
think about this so you don't think
there could be a barrier in a hundred
million years you don't think there
could be a barrier
to
like technological barrier
to becoming
expansionary
imagine the europeans that tried to
prevent anybody from leaving europe to
go to the new world
and imagine how what it would have taken
to make that happen over a hundred
million years
yeah it's impossible
they would had to have very strict you
know
guards at the borders
in the water saying no you can't go but
just just to clarify
you're not suggesting that's actually
possible
i am suggesting it's possible i i don't
know how you keep my silly human brain
maybe it's the brain that values freedom
but i don't know how you can keep
no matter how much force
no matter how much censorship or control
or so on i just don't
uh know how you can keep people from
exploring into the mysterious into the
end you're thinking of people we're
talking aliens so remember there's a
vast space of different possible social
creatures they could have evolved from
different cultures they could be in
different kinds of threats i mean there
are many things that you talked about
that most of us would feel very
reluctant to do yes this isn't one of
those but okay so how if the ufo
sightings represent alien visitors how
the heck are they getting here under the
transparent siblings so panspermia
siblings is one part of the scenario
which is that's where they came from and
from that we can conclude they had this
rule against expansion and they've
successfully enforced that
that also creates a plausible agenda for
why they would be here that is to
enforce that rule on us that is if we go
out and expanding then we have defeated
the purpose of this rule they set up
interesting right so they would be here
to convince us to not expand convince in
quotes right through various mechanisms
so obviously one thing we conclude is
they didn't just destroy us that would
have been completely possible right so
the fact that they're here and we are
not destroyed means that
they chose not to detroit they have some
degree of empathy or you know whatever
their morals are that would make them
reluctant to just destroy us they would
rather persuade us
for their brethren and so they may have
been there's a difference between
arrival and observation they may have
been observing for a very long time
exactly and they arrive to try to
not to try
i don't think to ensure try to ensure
that we don't become grabby
which is because that's we can see they
they did not they must have been forced
to rule against that and they are
therefore
here too that's a plausible
interpretation why they would risk this
expedition when they clearly don't risk
very many expeditions over this long
period to allow this one exception
because otherwise if they don't we may
become grabby and they could have just
destroyed us but they didn't and they're
closely monitoring the technological
advancing of civilization like what
nuclear weapons is one thing's like all
right cool
that might have less to do with nuclear
weapons and more with nuclear energy
maybe they're monitoring fusion closely
like how clever are these apes so no
doubt they have a button that if we get
too uppity or risky they can push the
button and ensure
that we don't expand but they'd rather
do it some other way so now
that's that explains why they're here
and why they aren't out there there's
another thing that we need to explain
there's another key data we need to
explain about ufos if we're going to
have a hypothesis that explains them and
this is something many people have
noticed which
is they they had two two extreme options
they could have chosen and didn't chose
they could have either just remained
completely invisible clearly an advanced
civilization could have been completely
invisible there's no reason they need to
fly around and be noticed they could
just be in orbit and dark satellites
that are completely invisible to us
watching whatever they want to watch
that would be
well within their abilities that's one
thing they could have done the other
thing they could do is just show up and
you know land on the white house lawn as
they say and shake hands like make
themselves really obvious
they could have done either of those
and they didn't do either of those
that's the next thing you need to
explain about ufos azaleas why would
they take this intermediate approach
hanging out near the edge of visibility
with somewhat impressive mechanisms but
not walking up and introducing selves
nor just being completely invisible so
okay a lot of questions there so one so
one do you think it's obvious where the
white house is
or the white house
obvious where there are concentrations
of humans that you could go up and into
but it's humans the most interesting
thing
yeah about earth yeah
are you sure about this because
if they're worried about an you know an
expansion then it would be worried about
a civilization that we could be capable
of transparent obviously humans are the
civilization on earth that's
by far the closest to being able to
expand i just don't know if aliens
obviously see
obviously see humans like the individual
humans like the organ
the meat vehicles as the center of focus
for observing
a life on a planet they're supposed to
be really smart and advanced like this
shouldn't be that hard for that but i
think we're actually the dumb ones
because we think humans are the
important things but it could be
our ideas it could be something about
our technologies mediated with us that's
correlated with that no we make it
seem like it's mediated by us humans
but the focus for alien civilizations
might be
the ai systems or the technologies
themselves that might be the organism
like what humans are like
okay human is the food the the source of
the organism that's under observation
versus like so like the what they wanted
to have close contact with was something
that was closely near humans then they
would be contacting those and we would
just instantly see but we would still
see but don't you think that
isn't it possible
taking their perspective
isn't it possible that they would want
to interact with some fundamental aspect
that they're interested in
without interfering with it
and and and that's actually a very no
matter how fast you are it's very
difficult to do but that's puzzling so i
mean the you know the prototypical ufo
observation
is a
shiny
big
object
in the sky that has very rapid
acceleration and
no apparent you know surfaces for
using air to to manipulate its speed
um
you know and
the question is why that right again if
if they just for example if they just
wanted to talk to our computer systems
they could like move some sort of like a
little probe that like connects to a
wire and like reads the
reads and sends bits there they don't
need a shiny thing flying in the sky
but i don't you think they would be
there they are it would be looking for
the right way to communicate the right
language to communicate everything you
just said
uh looking at the computer systems i
mean that's not a trivial thing
coming up with a signal that us humans
would not freak out too much about
but also understand might not be that
trivial
freaking out apart is an another
interesting constraint so again i said
like the two obvious strategies are just
to remain completely invisible and watch
which would be quite feasible or to just
directly interact let's come out and be
really very direct right i mean there's
big things that you can see around
there's big cities there's aircraft
carriers there's there's lots of if you
want to just find a big thing and come
right up to it and like tap it on the
shoulder or whatever that would be quite
feasible then they're not doing that
so
my hypothesis
is that
one of the other questions there was do
they have a status hierarchy and might i
think most animals on earth who are
social animals have status hierarchy
and they would reasonably presume that
we have a status hierarchy
and take me to your leader well i would
say their strategy is
to be impressive and sort of get us to
see them at the top of our status
hierarchy
just to just to
you know
that's how for example we domesticate
dogs right we convince dogs we're the
leader of their pack
right and we domesticate many animals
that way but as we we just swap into the
top of their status hierarchy and we say
we're your top status animals so you
should do what we say you should follow
our lead
so the idea that would be
they are going to get us to do what they
want by
being
top status
you know all through history kings and
emperors etc have tried to impress their
citizens and other people by having the
bigger palace the bigger parade the
bigger crown and diamonds right whatever
maybe building a bigger pyramid etcetera
just it's a very well established
trend to just be high status by being
more impressive than the rest to push
back when there's an order of uh several
orders the magnitude of power
differential asymmetry of power i feel
like that status hierarchy no longer
applies it's like memetic theory it's
like most emperors are several orders of
magnitude more powerful than anyone okay
a member of their empire
let's increase
that by even more so like if i'm
interacting with ants
right
i no longer feel like i need to
establish my power with ants i actually
want to lessen i i want to lower myself
to the ants i want to become the lowest
possible and so that they would welcome
me
so i'm less concerned about them
worshipping me i'm more concerned about
them welcoming me into it it is
important that you be non-threatening
and that you be local so i think for
example if the aliens had done something
really big in the sky you know 100 light
years away
that would be there not here yes and
that could seem threatening so i think
their strategy to be the high status
would have to be to be visible but to be
here and non-threatening i just don't
know if it's obvious how to do that
like take your own perspective if you
see a planet
with
with relatively intelligent like complex
structures being formed like uh yeah
life forms you could see this
under in titan or something like that
the moon you know right europa
you start to see not just primitive
bacterial life but multicellular life
and it seems to form some very
complicated cellular uh
colonies
structures that they're they're dynamic
there's a lot of stuff going on some
some giant gigantic cellular automata
type of construct
how do you make yourself
known to them
in an impressive fashion
without destroying it
like we know how to destroy potentially
right so
so if you go touch stuff you're likely
to hurt it right there's a good risk of
hurting something by getting too close
and touching it and interacting right
yeah like landing on a white house lawn
right so the claim is
that their current strategy of hanging
out at the periphery of our vision and
just being very clearly physically
impressive with very clear physically
impressive abilities
is
at least a plausible strategy they might
use to impress us and convince us sort
of we're at the top of their status
hierarchy
and i would say if they if they came
closer not only would they risk hurting
us in ways that they couldn't really
understand but more plausibly they would
reveal things about themselves we would
hate so if you look at
how we treat other civilizations on
earth and other people
we are generally you know
interested in foreigners and and people
from other plant lands and we were
generally interested in their varying
cult customs et cetera until we find out
that they do something that violates our
moral norms and then we hate them and
these are aliens for god's sakes right
there's just going to be something about
them that we hate they eat babies who
knows what it is
but something they don't think is
offensive but that they think we might
find and so they they would be risking a
lot by revealing a lot about themselves
we would find something we hated
interesting but do you uh resonate at
all with
memetic theory where like we only feel
this way about things that are very
close to us so aliens are sufficiently
different to where we'll be like
fascinated terrified or fascinated but
not like right but if they want to be at
the top of our status hierarchy to get
us to follow them they can't be too
distant they have to be close enough
that we would see them that way but
pretend to be close enough right right
and not reveal much that mystery that
old clintus would right cowboy
i mean
we're clever enough that we can figure
out their agenda that is just from the
fact that we're here if we see that
they're here we can figure out oh they
want us not to expand and look they are
this huge power and they're very
impressive so and a lot of us don't want
to expand so that could easily tip us
over the edge toward
we we already wanted to not expand we
already wanted to be able to regulate
and have a central community and here
are these very advanced smart aliens who
have
survived for 100 million years and
they're telling us not to expand either
this is brilliant
i love this so much uh the the returning
to penspermia siblings just to clarify
one thing
in that
framework
how would
who
originated who planted it would it be a
grabby alien civilization that planted
the siblings or no the simple scenario
is that life started on some
other planet billions of years ago yes
and it went through part of the stages
of evolution to advance life but not all
the way to advanced life
and then some rock hit it grabbed a
piece of it on the rock and that rock
drifted for maybe in a million years
until it happened upon the stellar
nursery
where it then seeded many stars and
something about that life
without being super advanced it was
nevertheless resilient to the harsh
conditions of space
there's some graphs that i've been
impressed by that show sort of the level
of genetic information in various kinds
of life on the history of earth
and basically we are now more complex
than the earlier life but the earlier
life was still pretty damn complex
and so if you actually you know project
this log graph in history it looks like
it was many billions of years ago when
you get down to zero so like plausibly
you could say there was just a lot of
evolution that had to happen before you
to get to the simplest life we've ever
seen in history of life on earth was
still pretty damn complicated okay and
so that race that's always been this
puzzle how could life get to this
enormously complicated level in the
short period it seems to
at the beginning of earth history so
where you know it's only 300 million
years at most it appeared and then it
was really complicated at that point so
panspermia allows you to explain that
complexity by saying well it spent
another five billion years on another
planet
going through lots of earlier stages
where it was working its way up to the
level of complexity you see at the
beginning of earth
we'll try to talk about other ideas of
the origin of life but let me uh return
to ufo sightings is there other
explanations that are possible outside
of pam's permanent siblings that can
explain
no grabby aliens in the sky
and yet
alien arrival on earth
well the other categories of
explanations that most people will use
is well first of all just mistakes like
you know you're you're confusing
something ordinary for something
mysterious right or
some sort of secret organization like
our government is secretly messing with
us and trying to do a you know a false
flag up or whatever right you know
they're trying to convince the russians
or the chinese that there might be
aliens and scare them into not attacking
or something right
because if you you know the history of
world war ii say the u.s government did
all these big fake operations
where they were faking a lot of big
things in order to mess with people so
that's a possibility the government's
been lying and you know faking things
and con
paying people to to lie about what they
saw etc that that's a plausible set of
explanations for
the range of sightings seen
and another explanation people offers
some other hidden organization on earth
there's some you know secret
organization somewhere that has much
more advanced capabilities than
anybody's given a credit for for some
reason it's been keeping secret i mean
they all sound somewhat implausible but
again we're looking for maybe you know
one in a thousand sort of priors
the question is you know
could could they be in that level of
plausibility
you